check-check Chinese check baby chicken
check chicken sausage chick hearn
chickpeas check check please
chicks Chicka doodle D remember
chickadees member that remember
chickadees it was a little like a
breakfast place I don't know if they it
was chickadees and you go in there and
they had um you know to give you the
menu and it was they would hand write
the menus every day which i think is
probably why they went out of business I
mean at that point you're more of a
calligraphy shop or something I mean
they'd hang I don't know they say home
of the handwritten menu that was their
big ticket that was their big you know
kitchen the door deal home at a
handwritten menu and then they hand
write him and then I don't know what
happened I don't know what happened on
Thor was a fire or something had
something happened over there but um but
anyway what's going on man not much
chickadees that was it and I go over
there and get me a little breakfast you
know give me a cut of ham get me a you
know to uh bird eggs to bird eggs and a
cut of ham for three dollars I'll
remember
and some I'm gonna have sweet sweet
entrees it said on there a little bonus
section on the menu it said I'll sweet
entrees and it have you look at you a
little hot cake or a you know arm
what's that food we won in the war
french toast get you you know get you a
little you know uh
savory item get you something like that
chickadees it was called and sometimes I
was when I missed school if I would miss
the school bus they had a man that would
take me to school and he I don't
remember his name but he was just kind
of a kind of a mysterious looking man
and he might have had I don't know
cancer or something but he had on his
son was named BIC Donald and his son was
named big Donald even though he was
little and and sometimes I would miss
the bus and his son I think it maybe
even dropped out of school but I would
miss the bus and the dad would take me
to school in his car and he drove a car
that was it wasn't a hearse but it was
like it seemed like a hearse you know
like they probably had ghosts in the
trunk kind of thing kind of vehicle you
know it was just I mean if you got in a
car accident in this car you were gonna
die because it was just real long and
black and I think it was a hearse but
they had sawed off the back and made it
into a regular car and and that was big
Donald's daddy and he would take me to
school when I would miss school or when
I would miss the bus and and sometimes
he would come out at first and he said
you missed it and I said I don't know
and he said maybe wait a little while
and I would wait a little longer and he
knew it had already passed he was just
kind of uh you know just getting me
calibrated for a life of I guess
uncomfort or of you know uncertainty I
don't know but he'd come out another
time did you miss it I you know I don't
know I don't know if I missed it I mean
it's 9:00 a.m. I'll be not here for an
hour and 45 minutes school started at
7:30 I probably missed it and he'd say
well just you know it could show up so I
sit there and way to start getting hot
I'm a book bag on fill my books heating
up filled my homework all hot I didn't
do my homework actually man I just feel
my books hot okay I'll be honest with
you but and then he say all right come
on I'll take you and I think since his
son had dropped out of school since his
boy had given up on you know knowledge
or blanket knowledge you know our
governmental knowledge really education
that they were you know that it was his
chance to still have that moment with
his son and we would ride we would ride
in the car and I would try to you know
practice it look at my book look at my
spelling and and he would blow cigarette
smoke over at me he'd be smoking a pack
of Doral's over there and he would dip
both windows up I mean I think he had
damn glued the window shut cuz he loved
all the smoke he wanted all the smoke
baby and he blow that smoke on me and
asked me to spell a word and I would
just try to you know my face was burning
my eyes were burning and I would try to
get that word out of me you know uh I in
I in see what is it buddy
what is it let me blow that smoke all my
food
like I in see Oh in spell it boy and
he'd yell at me spell it boy and he'd
even called me his son's name to
sometime spell it big Donald spell it
little Donald and he couldn't remember
sometimes if his son was named big
Donald or a little Donnell when you blow
the smoke on medians then he didn't uh
he didn't have a spell [ __ ] so he would
just kind of you know kind of oh there
you go there you go
and then he'd let me flick his cigarette
he'd hand it over to me and let me flick
it on her floor and uh but anyway we
stopped at this place called chickadees
and go in their home and a handwritten
menus and we get in there and and I'd
read him with a set on the menu and I
would read him straight up with a set on
the menu and I mean honestly man maybe
that man he might not even know to read
and maybe this was his way of just kind
of connecting with you know with an
education he never got fully or
partially even or semi partially you
know I don't know but chickadees I
remember and then they you know one
thing one guy the guy with the best
penmanship didn't come in or something
he got in a fight with his wife and then
and they didn't have a menu one day we
went in there and they didn't have a
menu and nobody knew what to do the cut
you know the waiter just the waitress
just standing there with her arms in
there and and the cook just [ __ ] gave
up you know just cracked a couple eggs
writing in his damn mouth and just
walked out and and I think they burned
the place down for insurance or in yeah
for insurance money but anyway what else
man let's get into the episode brother
again
you know
[Music]
how could I be so far tonight
oh come on boy put that negligee on come
on Donald big Donald come on falling
like these please cornerstone when I
reach that Brown in my bone will get
skeletal baby let's go a little time let
it hit your daddy gonna set that parking
brake and let myself fall I shine
on me come on big Donald
come on little Donald inconvenience what
can I get you just oh you you want them
over easy or what I've been moving way
too fast on the runaway train lower my
pants haven't we all baby
we're just tugging that past with us
right now
[Music]
see it'll probably still come just wait
out here it's almost noon shine a light
on me I'll sit and tell you my story
you want grits with that and all me your
mom stone I will sing it just oh you
there you go boy there you go
and that fade-out oh I couldn't get that
fade-out well right there but I want it
too I'll say that I wanted too good to
be here with you and it is middle of
July halfway to Christmas can you cut
down
I mean if you put your ear up to the dam
to the beach you can hear I mean you
could hear Santa just just just tighten
it up a couple toy trains out there you
know it's halfway to Christmas man good
to see you guys we are here July 20th
2020 the year 2020 in the future in the
past I'm not sure when this will you
know hit you and I don't know if you've
come from the future of the past to
listen to it I don't know how you got to
right now you know you may be some
people there may be a time in the future
where people are you know living in
Reverse and they just back in they're
backing into a day that you're just
getting to we don't know we don't know
that I'm at home and I do not want to be
that's how I feel man I don't even want
you know just give me a damn shovel and
no no knowledge and I'll Dan I'll try
digging to China you know remember that
when we were young they say you dig oh
you dig it you could dig to China dig
your hole you know your mom get out
there your grandmother get out there
give you a little shovel maybe your
uncle still one of those uh you know the
cement that
the cement things that break up the
cement you know maybe he steal one of
those from work and he lets you and your
buddy how each hold one handle of it cuz
it was too much that jackhammer and
y'all just just Jack Hammond that [ __ ]
up you out there digging and
jackhammering as children thinking oh we
gonna China but now you see some kid
digging to China you take the shovel
from them say hey buddy
uh-uh no no no we do not need we do not
need another thoroughfare between US and
China brother we can that's crazy that
children now aren't even allowed to dig
to China you know remember that
oh we're gonna we'll get there won't you
come back in the morning to dig more
somebody's how you know some man
sleeping in the hole her you know his
wife kicked him out he's doing drugs or
something or he was you know he ran out
of drugs and she kicked him out and he
peed in the damn hole and you should
just keep digging man piss dirt and all
just dig your way through you don't stop
but ya chickadees that was the name of
that joint I guess I don't know if they
something happened some insurance
scandal or something [ __ ] and they
shut it down but yeah I want to go I
want to just and I just got back I just
got back from the HAMP baby from New
Hampshire and now I want to go again I
want to go do something again you know
so sometimes when I can't travel you
know I'll travel inside of myself I'll
take a little vacation she's just a
specific time or a specific moment and
I'll try to remember all the things I
can about the moment sometimes when I
think of the past or when I think of
something I don't forget to think of all
the different things
of the senses you know because that'll
that gives my memory more you know more
bad or to make a cake out of you know I
remember one of the first times ever
even performed I was you know a child or
something I think I was a child I was
just a small adult that was just lying
about how old he was but I was a you
know just a middle-aged child or
something I don't know probably about
nine and if we were bad which we were my
mother would make us perform do a
performance so we could come downstairs
and watch rescue naamam one on
television because that was my show man
that was my thing that was my jam I love
to call 9-1-1 and some of you guys know
that about me and some of you don't I'll
call them matches I'll text them you
know I texted him from the Poirier
Holloway fight I said they got some damn
ruffians out here beating the [ __ ] out
of each other you know and they said
where are you I said I met them UFC
whatever it was 214 baby where you guys
do gang [ __ ] bring the fire department
but you can text anomaly one now but
when I was young I would call him I'd
call him for anything you know I called
him if we couldn't pay the bills I call
him hey yep st. Tammany Parish police
and fire I'm help you is this an
emergency
yep we can't pay the water mom can't pay
it so she you know she told her boss off
and she got fired so I'm sorry I'm you
I'm gonna have to keep the line free
fractional emergencies but at least I'll
let him know somebody got to let the
city know what you're thinking
you got to at least let him know what
you're dealing with you know but um but
anyway I remember you know that would
make us we'd had she didn't make us but
we would
down and perform you know we would put
paint or something on our bodies or put
a sheet on top of us and write China on
it maybe in do you know get in a like a
line and put a couple sheet on us and
make a dragon we come down and you know
you know my brother would beat a little
uh you know we'd have him beat up what
is it called a he would beat like a
tambourine with a spoon or you know we
had a we had a this man my mom dated
used to do fake accidents to get money
and so we had I remember like a metal
neck brace that he left over one time
and so sometime my brother would put
that on and get thimbles like you know
metal little thimbles from sewers
so where's kids and he would put him on
his fingers and so we'd all come down
and he would play kind of Chinese music
on his you know just you know playing
that that metal neck brace and uh and
the rest of us would just be in a damn
sheet we'd written shine on the side of
it and cut a couple eye holes out the
front and wrote dragon on the front and
we would do a show put on a show for Mom
and if she liked the show well enough
then we were allowed to sit there by the
television and watch rescue number one
or so you know a couple other programs
unsolved mysteries rescuing I'm on won
America's Most Wanted I mean we like to
watch it that was a very fear-based and
we would sit do we work in we would sit
literally two inches from the television
screen I mean our television was as big
as two iPhone nines I mean that [ __ ]
was big as two off like a double-wide
iPhone nine and we would sit there two
inches from it and just let it all just
let the devil just go straight into our
eyes and that was you know that was but
that was some of the first times we
would perform that I would perform
I remember as a child was coming down
and doing that and performing for Mom so
that we could watch rescue Nam on one
and Here I am you know 30 years later
still performing for television in a
weird way you know in kind of a
backhanded way but you know still
performing to to be a part of the show
so I could see the show whatever I don't
know about that part but what else man
but anyway but anyway yeah sorry I was
telling you so I would when I think back
to like if I can't go then I'll go
somewhere in my head you know I'll take
a you know think back to those times and
something so other things that I think
about from that time I think about the
carpet you know well how did it feel
how'd the carpet feel because we were
barefoot you know it was nighttime were
barefoot inside you know and and so I
think about think about how it felt to
my feet and then I remember the carpet
you know the color of it was kind of
called coffee with milk color in it and
um and so I think about that I think
about the smell what the smell would be
like well when we went to Mom's room to
perform they she had usually just gotten
out of the shower you know and she was
uh she wasn't nude anymore we didn't do
anything like that you had to go down
the street for some of that [ __ ] family
nudity kind of [ __ ] but but you could
smell up you know you could smell the
shampoo in the room you could smell a
salon selects and mom had salon selects
man in it Oh oh my god I do not know if
you remember salon selects it was um it
was about the most high-class shampoo
you could get I mean it had
I don't even know what it was made out
of it just seemed like they'd taken a
couple beautiful women and cream you
know and just put you know cremated them
or whatever and this put them right into
the damn bottle and then they put two
scoops of freaking California in there
and maybe half a scoop of hibiscus up in
there you know and then they just they
would trim an angel's wings right into
that [ __ ] heated up to about 240 and
then let it simmer and then bottle it
and your mom had it mom got Salon
selects we would wash our hair with a
soap you know we will wash our hair with
a soap or sometimes we would put a soap
bar in a sock and you would rub that on
your head so it's not to lose all the
soap you that way you weren't you know
the soap would stay in that sock you
weren't minima cuz otherwise you give us
a bar of soap somebody you know we'd use
it all in one bathing we'd bathe for two
and a half hours we use somebody you
know hide it in her ass or something
just you know children being children
but when mom when when and so what mom
did with mom put it in a sock and we
would just scrub it on her head so the
soap still came out of it but you just
weren't wearing that bar down and I
remember sometime I go over to a rich
kids house and they would have a little
bit of Irish Spring over there
and shout out to Ireland man and shout
out to uh you know shout out to Ireland
and in the UK and all of our good people
over there
you know shout out to Jack Shore who won
his MMA fight man young legend right
there and hell I hope they opened the
borders soon man cuz I think half of us
want to come back to England brother
I'll tell you that put me on a boat baby
I'm joking man I'm happy to be here but
some days there's some yeah you know I
live I live in California it's just a
little bit more I don't know too many
know-it-alls out here but anyway mom had
so um selects that's what I'm telling
you mom had that salon selects and if
you sometime I would say Oh mom I'm out
of shampoo I'd run into her room and I'd
reach my hand in the shower mom would be
in her shower you know which if I was
lucky boy she'd put a little salon
selection and the problem was my body
heat would start to kind of make it
thinner you know your body heat like you
can only hide jello in your hand for
about 40 minutes before you just got a
little handful of something and you have
to tell you have to you know tell people
hey this used to be gelatin on believe
you and that's what it was like so I'd
have to run all the way back upstairs
get back in the shower and put it in my
hair before it all kind of dissipated or
snuck out the you know the little cracks
in my fingers but damn I love that man
you know and I love when momma give me
some some of that salon selects and I
remember god I remember that boy and
sometimes I've washed my hair with it
and sometimes honestly broad washed my
damn body with it and sometimes honestly
honestly double honestly I'd frickin
lick a little bit of it right out of my
damn hand bro god damn forgive me but
God just they're just tasting that damn
hibiscus brother we didn't have hibiscus
by us so to just get a damn hit of it
out of that bottle but I remember that
was another thing I remember when I go
into mom's room you could smell that cuz
she had just showered
recently you know and so she you could
smell it in the air but anyway little
things like that just bring me you know
when I think of the when somebody's like
hey do you remember I try to think of
okay well what was something that I felt
at the time okay I felt the carpet I
remember that I remember uh you know how
my body felt when I was young it just it
I I was I wasn't aware of it now I'm so
aware of my body I'm you know I got to
move and I got to think about what I'm
doing
and you know I got a reach for something
it's all but when I was young it
everything was just it was just it went
from an idea or a thought in my head to
it an action there was no delay there
was no age in the gumming up the works
you know there was no door I'll smoke
between my brain and my activity you
know it was just immediate just just
chickadees on the table baby but yes I
did that's what I try to think of
sometimes when I'm thinking about
stories and I think I think of okay what
did I see what did I smell you know what
did I feel would it uh what was the
taste of something was there anything
you know was there you know just I try
and go through my senses and just and
that helps me add some memory sometimes
I think all of our memo everything we've
ever done is inside of us sometimes I
think that but you have to get some you
have to there needs to be a key to
unlock it like a person will talk to you
or remind you of something or or you
know different stuff like that today's
episode is brought to you by policy
genius I've got to let you know that
there's never a bad time to save money
and that really is true and it's really
never more true than it is right now you
know we don't know the future you know
even if you go to a soothsayer or you
know a crystal ball person and you say
hey what's gonna they - hands in the air
they don't know
so finding smart ways to put some cash
back in your pocket can make a big
difference one way to do that is to
simply save on the things you already
pay for that's easy like home insurance
if you own a home re shopping your home
insurance rates with policy genius could
save you a good chunk of change you need
that and the best part is you barely
need to lift a finger to do it just head
to policy
is calm and answer a few quick questions
about yourself and your property then
policy genius will compare your policy
against options from top insurers to
make sure you're getting the right home
insurance coverage at the best possible
price if policy genius finds you a
better rate than what you're currently
paying they'll do all the work to get
you switched own a car policy genius
will compare your home and auto policies
across different insurance insurers an
even mix and match they're looking to
find you savings they've saved their
customers an average of twelve hundred
dollars per year doing exactly that
finding new home and auto policies
across different insurers so if you'd
like to put a little cash back in your
pocket right now see how much you can
save by reshaping your home insurance
rates at policy genius.com all right
let's take a call here from Larry the
driver homeward I'm driving along here
and Larry drives hell I don't know where
he drives but he's left a lot of
voicemails about you know vehicle
operation and and that sort of thing so
let's see what he's doing going brother
and to my place of employment and I had
a thought I said who better to call from
connect a via to share the thought with
than the co bond one so I just saw a guy
neighbor he's walking his dog his dog
two German Shepherd very narrow face you
know they have features then I looked at
the guy and I'm like wow he's starting
to look just like that German Shepherd
in the face narrow kind of they were
going up a hill head pointed forward
face forward everything going up the
hill and then I saw yeah people I guess
maybe creatures do that we start to turn
into the things or start to look like
the things we looked at or the
or the being amen brother Thank You
Larry for that man you're right I think
you're definitely right about I mean
whoo I don't know if you're right or not
but yeah I mean you saw what you saw you
know it's like you're reporting a damn
UFO your reporting obviously a lien you
know guy who's a towel you know maybe
Judeo Italian going up hill with a
German Shepherd you know you saw what
you saw but yeah I think we start to
reflect what we focus on man it could be
a dog it could be a you know if you
listen to takashi 6:9 all day and watch
all of his videos which are awesome okay
I'll say that but if you do it all day
every day
next thing you know you're gonna get a
couple skittles embedded into your cheek
you know you're gonna braid your hair
you know you're gonna frickin be out of
work you're gonna be you know you're
gonna be hiding in a in a town house out
there and you know somewhere probably
you know Toledo or Boise but it's like
yeah you're gonna become whatever you
focus on but people do that with animals
for sure you'll see us you know you'll
see a lady with a shih tzu named Sharon
and then people start saying oh that's
Sharon Shih Tzu Sharon and both them
they got you know matching little side
ponies and you know they're both eating
out of a bowl or something by the back
door of her house it's just bizarre
stuff you see a lot of that you know you
see a lot of Megan you know you'll see a
lady who named Megan with a Maltese and
then were like oh that's a Maltese Megan
you know and you throw a frisbee and
Megan runs and you know tries to catch
that [ __ ] and gets hit by a UH Ford
Fayette bra and you like you know but
yeah people start to Envisat and become
what they the animals they have you see
it with riffraff even you know riffraff
who's that rare element he's the you
know he's the Bermuda Triangle of hugh
of humans
and he's got a couple Huskies and he
starts trying you know he starts to
mimic them and sound like them and move
like them you know you'll see him on all
fours pissing on a hydrant over there
down there near Deer Park Florida but
I'm just saying you know whatever we
spend time with you see that a lot
especially the dog human element that
combo package you know somebody gets a
you know your buddy Bernard gets a damn
Burmese python and next thing you know
Bernard you'll catch him one afternoon
laying on the street you know with no
shirt on putting his stomach on the on a
concrete to stay warm so there's a lot
of that type of [ __ ] but gang Larry
thanks for recognizing that and thanks
for the call man appreciate it and you
know just take care of yourself brother
all right you'd be good man onward all
right let's take another call right here
here we go APO this is Sam in Nashville
Tennessee here what's up Sam or Samuel
and Sam is often a short name for Samuel
or Yosemite Sam if you're a drawing you
know onward a lot of to ask you about
performing in 2020 I play drums for a
living here in Nashville or I did the
city got hit by a tornado back in March
okay you could have played in our
Chinese dragon retribution performance
that we did for Mom
homework sorry I wasn't even listening
right there because I started thinking
about that and anyway I'll back up did
he got hit by a tornado back in March
which took out some of the venues and
then shortly after that the core of it
took over which as you know cancels all
the tours and a lot of the gigs in town
too
a bunch of us positions here are talking
about organizing a protest to open up
some of these venues so we can get back
to doing what made Nashville famous and
make some music which we're currently
not allowed to do I know there's a lot
of folks out there that don't want us to
do that and I don't want anyone to get
but I guess I'd say stay home if you're
worried about it not trying to be
insensitive but really itching to go
back to work make some music and pay
somebody's bills I want to hear your
input since you're a performer and
you're feeling like struggles to do I
know that the virus is real and all that
just you know especially for people up
and coming it's just you know we got
bills so yeah brother I feel that man
thank you for the call and yeah that's a
lot y'all got a lot on the table
especially if you're up-and-coming if
you're trying to you were you were
building momentum and then all this
momentum you know just really slow do a
grind you know one thing I'll think
about that is it at least all
everybody's momentum slow to a grind so
it's even I think a lot of times it
feels like it's just us you know or just
you or just your band or and I'm not
saying you're saying that I'm just
saying sometimes it lands on us that way
but you know there's it's interesting
that it's everyone because we're not
used that's the element that we are not
used to is that everyone had to stop B I
feel you sometime I feel you you know my
mom said look if I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die you know she's ready to get out
there she you know she'll fist fight the
devil you know she's ready to she wants
to live what life she has remaining a
lot of people do large venues are tough
because a lot of them they don't want to
open up because it wouldn't even the
cost of to rent the space and everything
it's not even cost-effective to have a
show at it but if you have to have
people spaced out so far yeah I feel you
could you just have a show where it's
like hey if you want to come this is
just listen at your own risk why can't
that be a thing you know just listen at
your own risk that's it
you know I you know just like at the
pool they say oh wait you know if you
have a Bologna or something you know you
have a little bologna sandwich you have
maybe you know half a dozen tootsie
rolls or something in a barque soda and
they say don't swim don't swim but you
know Daniel Bryan he don't give a damn
dude
Daniel Dewey Daniel fillers Malfoy
freaking you know you know he'll put
he'll put three beef franks in his mouth
and jump straight in the deep end dude
he'll plan his funeral in the morning
and in dying afternoon bro you know
that's how he is he's risky like that
he'll we eat and swim at the same time
within a you know and he's never taken a
lesson he don't care that's who he is
so it just they should have an option I
feel like for people that want to be
Daniel and then it's you know I think
then it's like we get to see you know
we'll see what happens but I personally
I'd rather die over there at a damn
Billie eyeless show then I would just
hunker down watching 48 you know the
first 48 again it's like how do you want
to die you know you want to die that you
know that Louisiana children's
performance of the Chinese dragon or do
you want to die sitting at home watching
you know Clarissa explains it all or
something reruns
so yeah I'm ready you know I was just
looking yesterday talking to the agents
about getting a tent and maybe doing
shows like that maybe this will you know
maybe there will just be smaller shows
and there will be more traveling type of
shows coming up and it'll all take on a
new way that we embrace it you know I
don't know
I don't know man I wish I had some
solace for you but I feel you you know
I'm just itching to be the biggest thing
I mentioned a mission to not forget what
it was like before this because the more
and more this we live this that's what
starts to happen you forget how not
comfortable but just you forget what was
going on before and you kind of become
okay with this now and people say well
that's you know where there's risk to
that that's you know people could but
then here's the thing those people are
choosing to go die you know some I think
that's the core of a lot of it too some
people have a different view of life you
know and I'm sure this differs if you
have children if you don't but some
people they say you know they had that
mayor in Las Vegas and she's like well
let's open up and see you know I thought
that was pretty ballsy of her and of
course you can have people say what do
you tell you but some you know there's
some people think when they die they you
know there's another option they you
know it's not all about just this moment
you know there's that other there's a
deeper coil that were attached to and so
there's you know there's there's another
existence there's reincarnation there's
you know maybe you come back as a dragon
with China written on the side of you
there's something maybe you come back as
a damn you know as a French option over
there at chickadees bra but you know
like some people believe that so they
live life differently life's different
when you have this idea in your head
that there's
there's other dimensions there's other
levels you go on you know you look at
Super Mario differently and shout out
some boy of bacon arts who made this
right here and this is super Mario
looking like a bacon but but then
there's some people who you know it this
is it this is it and so they're so
caught they you know they don't have
that extra those next levels that they
have in their psyche and so they think
it's all right here right now this is it
but so then of course those types of
people are gonna have different views on
what's going on and how we react to it
in nature but and then there's Brendan
Schaub who almost single-handedly took
out the entire podcast universe so you
know there's just different types of
folks just joking and uh but keep but
not joke and you get it let's take
another call man here we go yeah this is
Lauren from Boston and I am calling
because I love and like you alright
Lauren
appreciate the good words thank you for
calling onward I saw you at the Wilbur
theater last March in Boston my friend
Kevin took me for my birthday we had
super good seats right up front you were
so funny you even at the beginning
seemed a little bit nervous and then you
crushed it your openers were awesome we
neither of us had ever heard of them and
they were they were awesome to be
introduced to but I'm calling because I
am from New Hampshire originally and
shout out ham shout out in ham baby live
free or die son you know that that's
their motto and maybe that would be a
good place to have those types of
concerts brother who called in a minute
ago you know out there in New Hampshire
where you know they got Dunkin Donuts
they got a cemetery right there
you go to the show you know you hit the
urgent care after and in boom you're in
a cemetery oh if it doesn't work out
otherwise you live in free gang man
homework that that rural outskirt where
you know before Trump America was a
thing it was Trump America Confederate
flag up North trucks with with kids
people say yes spelled y UT yeah yeah
and a lot of those folks you know became
Trump voters and I'm down here in Boston
I went to college here and I stayed here
and um it's hard to explain to people
the nuance you know the I'm a FEMINIST
I'm progressive in many ways and I still
have love and respect for the people I
grew up with and I feel like a lot of
that is being washed away on both sides
then there are little places where it
still lives and you help remind people
of that that you can be many different
kinds of a person and love then many
different kinds of people and I just
appreciate it well man this audio is
Jackie today um thank you for the call
young lady and I think it's nice that
your boy Kevin took you out there to see
the show and that's a real you know when
you get out there to see to show this
really I mean man it's fun I feel like
you know I've said before a lot of times
I want to be on the I want to be sitting
in the audience I don't want to be up
there on the stage I want to be out in
the audience and just and be able to
enjoy the show you know and I do enjoy
it but it's just a different type of
thing yeah you know you know there's a
look there's a lot of people in America
that that are gonna vote for Donald
Trump you know there's a lot of people
that like him you know certainly in the
the places that I grew up and there's
people that are in my family that that
love him you know
there's people that don't there's people
that don't love him but that will vote
for him there's people that that that
will vote for Biden if he runs they're
well they're you know there's there's
all types but I do think it is inter
sting how you know I don't I'll never
turn my back on any of those types of
people I don't care I don't think anyone
should tell you who to who to vote for I
really really don't I think that's your
thing and it gets to me how I see how
people were I'm from or people I see how
people that love Donald Trump love him I
see how they support him and I don't
know I mean I think there's some people
that love him but I think there's some
people that just vote for him but I see
why I certainly see why when it comes to
being poor and white because nobody
everywhere else everybody else looks at
you the media makes funny all the time
the only people you can make fun of
still are poor white people you know on
any television shows it seems like you
know if you're from a poor white place
they they immediately say you're racist
they say you're dumb you know they look
over us I don't know I don't know but
yeah I don't if you I don't care who you
vote for I hope you vote for somebody
that that you like I really do and I
don't care what side of the track that
they're on I really don't you know I've
voted for candidates on both sides every
time you can legally do that but anyway
I didn't mean to just kind of ramble on
a lot of that stuff but uh but yeah you
know I it's it hurts me it hurts me a
lot of times when I hear people say
certain things because they just assume
you know they assume that people were on
from a racist but you know many times we
spent building Habitat for Humanity
houses going to help with those for poor
black families in our area and we didn't
have a house
you know I was on the same bus as those
kids you know but what do you know you
just you know you can't Harbor on the
stuff you just try and do your best and
you know but I've seen a lot of great
stuff from a lot of the areas that other
people these days and a lot of other
people it's just the media it seems like
definitely seems to look down on except
for when they want to sell you something
boy they'll take your money so that's
what people start to do is just be
careful where they put their money you
know because perspective is some people
their perspective is just one thing so
it's like you can't get angry at a fish
for being in water man you can't get you
just you can but is it really jug that
justifiable if all the fish knows is
water you ever hear telling them about
air he don't know about air you know and
I'm pretty you know fortunate I've been
able to you know I've been I've been
fortunate to you know kind of just spend
time right on the beach you know in
there and in the water and and um and
both are awesome man gang bro but anyway
I didn't mean we robbed right off that's
a lot of political [ __ ] man I shouldn't
uh you know some of them I don't like
talking about a lot of that kind of
stuff but but we got too much stuff to
dividing us these days and they win when
they divide us they win you know that
gang bro let's take another call that
came in right here gang brawn work it up
deal
[ __ ] you know I'm coming from Vegas
having this [ __ ] on my mind
I don't know what to do dog I'm about to
have a baby sitting home Oh
congratulations brother that's awesome
man if you get a baby dude then you know
you get a real gift you know to think
that somebody is entrusting you with the
life that's pretty amazing
you know that's crazy that the other
side of existence is straight-up mailing
you a life out of your girl's body dog
that's crazy bro
that's the original FedEx right there
son
gang I went to my girls like Facebook
and on a [ __ ] kind of friend now like
like a low-key little home before I go
with her and she was like [ __ ] some
[ __ ] flow I don't even know like a
month before she met me and [ __ ] I've
been on her like Facebook and I see like
all the [ __ ] most look at she used to
have like liking the pictures and all
that [ __ ] she don't have a Monday no
more but I'm gonna had to check her like
[ __ ] at least [ __ ] three times
about that [ __ ] and like I'd be finding
shed light on her conversations with
like her [ __ ] family you know that
and she's all her talking about how she
used to [ __ ] have more [ __ ] up in
her [ __ ] apartment dang bro I
appreciate the call you know that man
I'm sorry that you know I can certainly
you know I've had a lot of experiences
with jealousy you know and I'm not
accusing you of being jealous but you
know um you know you got a good
opportunity right now you know all the
things you said she used to do before
y'all were together she had a life
before you guys you know that man so
it's um you know it's really you know
you got it I mean you can't you got a G
up
maybe have a Red Bull or something and
just you need to I think you got to find
some ways to forgive or man I think you
have to bro because you can't betray you
gonna drag all this stuff along forever
you know I'm sorry to hear that but you
can't what was your past like you know I
used to be real angry at my girl and
then I realized damn my past was sketchy
bruh hell my current is sketchy
I'm sketchy now so you know when I've
had a girlfriend it's like damn you know
I used to get angry brycie get angry at
my girlfriends do my first girlfriend
one time I got so angry cuz she dated
this guy before me and I like held that
[ __ ] against her you know I made her
feel bad and stuff man she couldn't just
she couldn't do nothing about that man
that was before I even knew her so you
know I think you just gotta find some
ways you got a baby coming like there's
you know God is giving you this gift
between you and this girl so it's
obvious that there's some real power
there between you guys and I know it's
gonna be hard man but I think you just
got to forgive her and just let you have
to let it go you know maybe even find
somebody to talk to about it I think
that that could help man I really really
do you know and I'm sorry to just kind
of sound like I'm telling you what to do
but I just want you to see you enjoy
this experience I don't want to see you
look back and you know cuz it sounds
like you're just angry and are you I
don't even know if you're really angry
at her if you just if you're just angry
you know and I don't know I just the
last thing we need in this world is some
kid coming into it in you know when
people fighting over the past we've got
enough fighting over the past going on
in the world you know and so I think if
if you can do it man you got a leg you
got all you got to let some of that
stuff go and be a cool day and start a
new adventure with her
you know I know it's really hard but you
can like just be supportive of her and
just be a man so so she doesn't have to
be with these fools anymore you know
you're lucky you caught her from these
fools you know and a lot of Latinos man
they'd like to fight in a car wash I
remember I went to school over there in
Tucson and kids always fist fighting
over there in the car wash and then
somebody get the suds gun and [ __ ] go
to town on some little dude you know
little actor getting you know oh you
like the limpio actor you like the
limpio papa so it's you know it's just
you can do it bro but you know I would
find somebody that you could talk to
that they can really help you about it
um and maybe even go into like a 12
steps for anger Anonymous or something
and I'm not trying to call you out I'm
not trying to say you're a bad guy or
anything like that I'm really not you
know you were just people bro and it's
not easy being people but that baby man
you're gonna I just want you to have fun
with that baby you know and you got a
great chance she don't have a baby with
any of those fools brought you to one so
go get it done daddy you can do it you
know I really think you can do it all
right let's take one more call here
actually this is a good uh this is a
good place to let you know right now
about better help that this episode is
brought to you by better help better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 24 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise in better
helps counselor network which may not be
locally available in many areas you know
it's interesting we'll get like a gym
membership but we won't get a membership
to take care of ourselves emotionally
and I think better help offers you that
you get timely thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
you know I had a counselor on there and
we would talk on the phone and sometime
we would Skype and even if I needed
someone an emergency situation better
help offer that better help wants you to
start living a happier life today visit
better help.com slash Theo that's B e TT
ER h ELP and join the over 500,000
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional that's right
special offer for this past weekend
listeners get 10% off your first month
at better help.com slash th e o what
else do we have man should we get into
one more call here we go let's take this
hit or getting hey Mike question I want
to run by you just move to a new town
and I've got a little bit of money saved
up and I work full time and I think
about starting off the side business and
the four years I've been looking into it
I think I'm ready to finally go I think
I'll start my own ice cream truck
business okay I'm really excited to
start looking into it right away all my
friends are kind of cuckoo and the idea
they called haters baby they called
haters Michael Moore Sam's creepy and
that you know pedophilia ideology
surrounding the whole thing which I
never thought about well you definitely
should have thought about that man you
know we had a guy bus they had a company
called Perry's putt-putt and they sold
mini golf to children and hell I don't
even know if they sold it to us I think
if you just showed up and had shorts on
that the man would let you play it and
the man I think this man mr. Perry he
would get out there and he would that's
every now and then he would spin the
boys around in a circle you know and he
would grab you by your feet and he would
spin you around
and uh everybody would laugh and stuff
and half the time you draw it or you
know spit up a dam now and later or
whatever you'd had for lunch but but
yeah it was a real real [ __ ]
establishment but um but you got to
think about that yeah you can't
I wouldn't go alone out there you know
if you go in wealthier neighborhoods
it's going to be different you're gonna
deal with the kid is gonna come to the
thing with the parents or with a
babysitter but dog you roll down the
East Miggy Street over there and
Covington Lousiana sign you gonna have a
frigate you know you gonna have a couple
seven six year olds some kid trade you a
video game some kid trade you a freakin
on you know maybe a um a picture frame
with his grandmother in it people do
more trade and barter for that astro pop
you know for that little Mickey Mouse
with the gumball nose or give you that
for that but that Bananarama you know
slick you know thing you know that
banana fudgesicle so [ __ ] I say do it
man but I would I would get a different
type of music I would do country music
or get crunk with it you know Karl's
country cream van that's what I'd call
it Karl's country cream van and every
now and then you pull over and get out
and do a dance do something come with a
real-ass hustle that way at least if a
kid gets diddled out or something are
you even flirting with a kid at least
they you know you brought some
entertainment to the village first
otherwise you get these [ __ ] rolling
through the neighborhood all they want
to do is touch kids and make make cream
money you know and they're not you know
they're not doing nothing but but yeah
man I think it sounds pretty cool bro I
think hey you know I pull I'd get me one
of them Astro pops I don't you know you
get I love Astro pop so I give you 75
cents for it you know or let you feel my
elbows bro
you know that [ __ ] boys shut out Perry
shut up Perry's putt-putt real rotgut
establishment over there all right I'll
take one more call here let's get a gang
what's up odds with the bar that a this
is Denzel Washington okay a bar mellows
man I'm calling from Canada damn brother
Oh Lord baby we got a fella he's calling
from Memphis ganna stannis Memphis baby
oh yes home of the first 48 bruh if you
like a little bitter herb and murder
bruh cracking it at gang Robert I just
had three questions for you first one
was have you ever been to Memphis for a
show or for anything yes sir and I've
been in Memphis man I've been down there
on Beale Street where they got the
people drinking by the goats I've been
over there you know I've been over there
and seen I've been over to Sun Studios
I've driven over off the Tupelo and seen
where Elvis was lived as a baby you know
I've been over there in a Memphis of it
at a Peabody Hotel what a duck's roll
through there you know I've been over
there baby and I love it man gang I love
Tennessee homework like that if not you
should come we'll definitely keep you
safe
I love how that's your new motto in
Memphis dude we'll keep you safe for us
then if you've ever seen the first 48
bruh that's Memphis's new motto we'll
keep you safe
ruff oh man I appreciate it
whoo you are a very beautiful man and
that isn't gay because I like women
sexual but I just had to let you know
that you are a very beautiful man
thank you brother and I appreciate that
and I feel a little bit more beautiful
than I used to when I was young which is
interesting because I was I was
definitely handsomer when I was young is
that more blood in my body and more you
know tighter cells and everything and I
feel you man there's nothing wrong
nothing gay about that you know there's
nothing real there's nothing real real
gay about it if you think another man is
I mean it's a little is
definitely kind of late night you know
cocaine vibes kind of if you say that
you know that's a beautiful mammatus
homework I know part of it has to do
with that mullet but even without the
mud you're still very beautiful
it's a haircut it's a hockey haircut
really rough you I don't you ever watch
hockey or been to a Europe which is
another country but they have they have
more unique hair there you know and
shout out hands their nation bro gang
over and I just had to let you know that
I appreciate you Theo von
dude you said three questions I got was
one question and he told me I'm
beautiful bro that's flirting so to be
real honest that's flirting man you know
and but hey whatever man
look I'll say this dude what about this
bro and no homo at all you know if you
feel me bro no homo but if you had to
take a man out on a date this for
anybody out there and it's for straight
men straight men only if you had to take
a man on a date on a first date you had
to take a man say you go over there you
go over to the get you know to the side
of the tracks where men love men and you
know what I'm talking about
I'm sexuals say you do it right and it's
great if you do if you look if you want
that if you want that in your life do it
but if you're a straight man what kind
of date would you take a man on if you
were gonna take a man out I'd love to
hear some of those calls nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three we'll
get into some of those next week if you
were really to be you know being do
being wild with them you know if you
were gonna take a man out but you're not
gay but you were gonna take a man out
and I think it's really straight of us
to even talk about this and uh you know
to you know in its
nothing wrong with that man so yes if
you got that man hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three yeah I want to thank everybody I
want to thank you guys for the call a
lot of great calls you know I want to
hope that everybody staying safe out
there you don't want to apologize if I
said anything that's that is just kind
of too political or anything like that I
know people get enough of that in the
world but but you know I'm you know I
can't help where God put me into the
world at and you know I feel like you
know I feel like I have to believe that
we're all headed into a best direction
you know and I believe that I really do
because I don't think that I just don't
think that the this whole adventure of
being human is supposed to turn out bad
sometimes I want to I want to it's fun
to think of Anarchy and you know it'd be
fun to play Robin Hood and get on your
roof and you know shoot people down and
stuff and that kind of [ __ ] but you know
it's I don't I think that we're all
headed over all into the best into best
practices you know so but anyway man I
love you
and uh and you guys be good to
yourselves man you know you deserve it
and thanks for the calls and we'll get
out to the rest of them next time and
gang
[Music]
celebrate live
celebrate misery
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die
celebrate dark days celebrate all y'all
bang
all of demons exorcised let's have some
fun while we all die I also wanted to
thank all of our patreon supporters you
know we just put a new video up on there
too just so you can check it out and you
know I know we've pared down our patreon
and made it very limited of what we're
offering there it's just basically a
very low level support of $2 but still
there's a lot of people that choose to
make that support and and I just want to
say thank you very much you guys be good
to yourself gang